[Music]  was the night before life day  in a galaxy far far away looking good  tree food decorations coming together  heroes were  to celebrate the day please be okay  please be a cape  that's a wrap for ray adventure called  and she thought it would be fast wow but  there she found a key to the galaxy's  past  sorry oh marlon what are you doing  this is so cool we've seen my master my  master's master concentrate my master's  father  impressive my master's father's master  dipper or palpatine  i don't believe it uh you think maybe  you could put a shirt on  it's a key to travel across space and  time  i will change to the future so sure are  you  mm-hmm let's talky more fighty fighting  hard races  oh so cute  you thinking what i'm thinking music  a time of joy this is ray a friendship  a family  who are you guys master skywalker my son  i mean my these binary sons  you want to shoot first after you  [Music]  you